Now listen to this.
There is some truth that if you're not
able to love yourself, then it's going
to be hard for you to love others. You
know why? Because Jesus says to love
your neighbor as yourself. You
understand? Jesus right there is
implicitly telling you, right, not to
hate yourself and despise yourself and
hate
how you were made. that you should have
love for yourself but not the love that
will make you the focus of attention,
make you an idol, right? Where you
become
a narcissist because he says the second
greatest command is love your neighbor
as yourself. Look, if loving yourself
was evil, he wouldn't say love your
neighbor as yourself. You see? So,
there's a truth in that statement. Mark
12:31,
there's no commandment greater than
these. And didn't Paul even say, "Love
your wife as your own body. No one harms
their body but cares and nourishes it."
See, that's true. But if you don't love
your body and you don't love yourself,
it's hard then to love your neighbor as
yourself because you don't love yourself
to begin with.
And it's hard to love your spouse as
your body because you don't love your
body to begin with.
See that?
You caught it there?
Now watch here. Paul says, "Husbands,
love your wives as your own body." Well,
what if you hate your body?
I'm sorry.
What if you hate your body? Then what?
You see the principle there? If loving
yourself was a sin, then the Lord would
tell you, "Stop loving yourself." And he
wouldn't say, "Love your neighbor as
yourself." And if loving your body was a
sin, then Paul would not say, "Love your
wives as your own body." After all, no
one harms their body, but nourishes and
cares for it. Here's the principle. God
wants you to take care of your temple,
not destroy it through addiction to
food, obesity, or you get sick. That's
why I beg Jesus, deliver me, right? Or
drugs, right? whether cocaine or heroin
or whatever it is, alcohol or even
steroids or growth hormone because these
will destroy your temples, your bodies,
right? Husbands, love your wives just as
Christ loved the church and gave himself
up for her to make her holy, cleansing
her by the washing with water through
the word and to present her to himself
as a rated church without stain or
wrinkle or any other blemish but only in
blameless. In the same way, husbands
ought to love their wives as their own
bodies. Wait, you know it is here. If
loving your body enough to care for it
and loving yourself was wicked, then why
would Jesus say, "Love your neighbor as
yourself?"
Why would Paul say, "Love your wives as
your own bodies?" He who loves his wife
loves himself. After all, no one ever
hated their own body, but they feed and
care for the body just as Christ does
the church.
See? See the principle? You have you
have a principle here where God says you
do not idolize yourself, worship
yourself, and make yourself the focus of
everyone's attention and love. That's
narcissism. That's Satanism. That's
idolatry. But you don't hate yourself.
I made you the way you are. I gave you
your personality. Though fallen and
tainted by sin, I will take care of
that. acknowledge the sinfulness. I will
then transform you and order you. All
right? But I made you your gender. I
don't make mistakes. Right? Your
personality
is your personality. I didn't make you
to be someone else. The only thing you
need is to be purged, purified of those
sinful elements that have tainted the
image of God in you. And that's where
the spirit comes and cleanses you and
purifies you and purges you and
transforms you. But the Lord wants you
to love yourself not to the expense of
loving anyone else, but as a healthy
love for who you are and how God made
you.
You understand here?
So, what has been my cross? What has
been my demon? What has been the thorn
of my side? I've had a hard time all my
life loving myself.
I've always thought I'm fat, obese, and
that people see me the way I see me as
an ugly fat slob. Even when I was 197
skinny, I still thought I was fat. So,
I've learned this is my cross. This is
my thorn. This is a demon I will fight
until I die. And I pray I die in union
with Christ so I can rest.
Okay,
do you guys see it now?
You see how profound and rich your body
is? I'm sorry, your Bible is. Lord, save
me from errand stammering confusion.
Give me perfect recall of every jour
scripture, perfect exesus. Destroy
errors in us and sin in us. And give us
the power to be doers of the word, not
hypocrites. To love you, father, love
you lord Jesus Christ. love you, Holy
Spirit.
Okay, you see that here?
So, you see here
that God didn't call you to hate
yourself,
but he didn't call you to worship
yourself, love yourself, and put
yourself ahead of others. There has to
be balance.
There has to be a balance
because the Lord would not say love your
neighbor as yourself if loving yourself
was wickedness. Anything to the extreme
becomes wickedness and evil. Right?
Eating too much, that's gluttony. That's
a sin. Being addicted to sex, that's
sin.
These are good pleasures that God gave
to be used lawfully
in the right context in an order orderly
way.
Right? So that's why you'll find
statements such as this
1 Timothy 4:8.
For physical training is of some value,
but godliness has value for all things.
holding promise for both the present
life and the life to come. Notice Paul
is saying yes physical training is
valuable.
So he didn't say be lazy fat glutton.
No he didn't say that you should engage
in physical training because it has some
benefit temporarily
right earthly but godly training
spiritual training is greater and more
important. So we need to be disciplined
spiritually, physically and have strict
discipline spiritually, physically to be
able to do that physical training so we
become healthier and not sicker because
even our health can be used to hinder
us. But spiritual training is of greater
value because at the end of the day no
matter how much you work out you still
die. But when you engage in intense
spiritual disciplines and training,
those rewards have everlasting
and it will exalt you and glorify you.
And then when you are raised at the end
of the age, then you'll have a body
that's morally incorruptible and
physically immortal.
You get it?
You understand that?
He said right here
because at the end of the day, Hulk
Hogan still died. Bruce Lee still died,
right? Franco Columbo still died. Sergio
Olivia still died.
All these athletes, these superhuman
athletes still die. Schwarzer is going
to die. Lou Frigo is gonna die.
Sylvester Salone's going to die.
So I don't care how many hours you
train, you still will die. That's what
Paul is saying.
But the man of God who does the will of
God lives forever and ever and ever.
See the point? Bruce Lee was 32 years
old. What did all that training get him?
Misery and an early grave.
Hulk Hogan dead at 71.
Two failed marriages was on wife number
three.
Right.
How many greats have died,
athletes,
physical specimens that were a sight to
behold? Dead.
Dead.
Right. Ronnie Coleman. Exactly.
So this is the whole point. This is what
Paul is saying. So that's just something
as a reminder to all of us. Speaking of
which, pray for Scott Feice fights.